when a satellite system that controls
the weather starts acting weird a
scientist must race against time devoted
to cataclysm from hitting the earth
today on cinema recap
i'll show you
geostorm a netflix movie the film begins
with the explanation that humanity was
warned about climate change but nobody
listened so temperatures increased ocean
patterns changed and the polar ice caps
melted all of which they called extreme
weather
they did not yet know what extreme
weather meant in the year 2019 there
were many weather catastrophes events
such as hurricanes tornadoes floods and
droughts unleashed a wave of destruction
on the planet in madrid a heat wave
killed two million people in just one
day
so when all the countries talked about
it they realized that none of them could
face this wave of disasters on their own
the world decided to unite and fight so
scientists from all over the world
gathered led by the united states and
china acting not of the interests of
their individual countries but on behalf
of humanity itself scientists created
the technology with a network of
thousands of satellites to neutralize
the basic elements of the climate
temperature pressure and humidity
all monitored by the international space
station these satellites easily undo the
clouds of a storm so that humanity can
take a break
but something important and dangerous is
realized they could also be used to
create catastrophes since they interact
with the base elements
then we meet a man named jake who is the
person who directed the construction of
the satellites
and he is going to a meeting with
justices from the united states and we
see that these people want to control
the technology
so they can control the weather the men
threaten jake with removing him from
command if he does not follow the orders
and also tell him that he will have to
fire people from his team since they
will be sending new personnel later we
meet max jake's younger brother
who warns his brother not to mess with
those men as they will ruin his project
max confesses that he was ordered to
command the international space station
and that he has a strict order to leave
jake out of the project so he tells him
that he's sorry since there were very
clear orders three years pass and an
army arrives in the desert in
afghanistan where it is very hot but
when they reach their destination they
realize that there is ice in the middle
of the sand
they enter a village and notice that
it's all frozen including people
elsewhere the personnel involved in
climate control and the president meet
they analyzed the problem concluding
that the satellites failed so they will
have to find a highly trained person to
go up and repair them
the president explains that in two weeks
per the contract they will have to cede
command of the satellites to china so it
does not want to deliver a damaged
project and therefore we ask them to
solve it quickly they leave the meeting
and a man from the committee tells max
that his brother jake is the best person
for this mission
but this does not please max since his
brother has already been fired
in space some workers isolate the
satellite that monitored the afghan
desert
one of them connected a device to
secretly download information
someone wanted him dead though shortly
after hatches supposedly fail
and the man is ejected into space
a few days later max goes to jake's
house where he sees the little daughter
of his older brother named hannah
then the brothers chat for a while max
explains to him the situation regarding
the failure of the satellites so he asks
for his support to find the solution but
jake refuses since he was kicked out of
his own project
max tells him that more people will die
if he refuses
so jake reluctantly agrees to join again
on the other side of the world in hong
kong a man named chang observes the
catastrophe that happened in afghanistan
he goes out to buy some things in hong
kong but notices that the ground starts
to burn so he quickly gets in his car to
escape the city hong kong is devastated
by nature entire buildings fall one by
one while cheng manages to get out along
with several people who watch how their
beautiful city burns and flames a few
days later jake gets on the ship back to
the space station
he's very happy since working in space
again gives him a lot of hope later they
introduce him to his new work team
they're adesa from structural
engineering
duncan taylor from systems
hernandez from robotics and doucet from
communication and security meanwhile on
earth cheng calls max to tell him what
happened but also that someone from the
united states has blocked his access to
the hong kong satellites
so he warns him that if the satellites
fail
they could create
great destruction
max does not fully understand so chang
explains it if the satellites fail they
could cause the so-called geostorm a
wave of multiple natural disasters which
will group together and make a great
storm of colossal levels chang tries to
find the flaw but some guys come and
almost catch him although they only take
the information on his desk
at the same time as jake knows the
satellites very well he quickly puts the
staff to work to find the failure max
and jake communicate and max lets his
brother know that someone has blocked
their access to the satellites so they
both agree to hurry up before worse
things happen
the hong kong satellite arrives at the
main station to be analyzed but a
robotic arm that supports the device
begins to fail and ends up destroying it
therefore they will not be able to
extract the information they need chang
arrives at dc and calls max to explain
what's going on
since he comments that he has discovered
everything
meanwhile jake and the station chief
find out that the glitches and murder of
the man at the station were staged
someone is sabotaging everything max and
his girlfriend try to meet with chain
but he gets killed before he dies he
tells max the words zeus project several
times
then jake in a secret message lets max
know that there is someone very high up
who is involved in everything and trying
to ruin the space station
so max begins to investigate about the
zeus project
trying to relate everything meanwhile
jake and the boss discover that the man
that was murdered was not a spy or a
traitor but that he had discovered the
flaws and made a copy of the files in
his locker before he died with that
man's information they discover a virus
has been implanted in the entire
satellite system and it only appears
that everything is failing so that no
one discovers the virus
in the meantime
max discovers that the zeus project is a
series of simulations to cause disaster
on earth on purpose
using the satellites
later both brothers communicate safely
thanks to a hacker
jake tells him that he believes that the
president is behind everything since to
get rid of the virus they need some
codes that he has
max can't believe that his precious
president is behind this atrocity so he
says goodbye to jake telling him to
watch from above while he will watch
from below max plans to steal the codes
from the president and taking advantage
of the fact that his girlfriend is part
of his personal security detail
they plan how to do it aboard the
station 200 satellites are seen to fail
which causes multiple catastrophes on
earth for example in tokyo hail of
unusual size destroys the city on a
beach in brazil the water freezes and a
wave of icy wind freezes everything in
its path including people
so jake and his team send another
satellite to collide with the current
one which should stop these events
however in brazil the wave continues to
freeze everything
so birds fall dead in seconds and a
plane passing by at the same time also
falls frozen then they manage to destroy
the satellite so brazil will be safe
jake gives the order to destroy the
other faulty satellites but the system
is interrupted by two things
the first is that in an hour and a half
a geostorm will appear
in which all humanity could die
the second is that the virus initiated
the main stations self-destruct jake
finds out that duncan implanted the
virus so he hits him a couple of times
finding out that he did it for money and
after a few struggles he accidentally
gets him ejected into space max tells
his boss deckham about what is happening
so he tells him the codes are biometric
which are from the president himself and
therefore they'll need his fingerprints
and retina deckham tells max that they
will have to talk to the president to
make him come to reason so he takes him
to a room where the president will
arrive
but deccan betrays him and starts
shooting max runs away to hide from
dekum since he is the one behind all the
attacks so he talks to his girlfriend
telling her to get the president out of
there since the next target of the
satellites is a place where he'll be
giving a lecture max's girlfriend
creates a distraction to get the
president out the back door where max is
waiting for them in a car
they leave the place before decom finds
them elsewhere the virus and the
satellites creates tornadoes in india it
also increases the temperature in russia
melting tons of ice in minutes max
explains to the president what is
happening and he believes him since the
catastrophe came and destroyed the area
where he was a mere moment ago deckham's
men continue shooting at them trying to
kill them all but max's girlfriend makes
some fancy maneuvers and shoots at the
assailants getting rid of them however a
man of decoms fires a rocket launcher
and destroys the car the president was
in
although it was actually a trick by the
president to unmask deckham they arrest
ekkum while in dubai the satellites
create a big wave of water that hits the
whole country max takes the president
input as biometric codes although they
find out that the codes will stop the
satellites but will not stop the
self-destruct of the main space station
where jake is so the brothers get
sentimental jake gets the president's
codes and goes on to stop the geostorm
but he runs into several problems since
the ship is heavily damaged and losing
gravity he manages to insert the codes
at the last second and save humanity
and then comes up with an idea to escape
using one of the satellites the station
explodes and everyone on earth gets very
sad since the two heroes who stayed in
the station have died but shortly after
they realized the satellite in which
they improvised an escape was saved
so another ship manned by hernandez
saves them everyone celebrates while the
catastrophes stop and jake lands on
earth
then the president congratulates both
brothers for saving humanity
six months pass
max jake and hannah are calmer
while the main space station is being
rebuilt
but this time with more security and
jake will be working on it the end
if you liked this video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
recaps of the best sci-fi in action
series and movies
thanks for watching